welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of 2003's
X2 X-Men United this is the second
installment of our X-Men stick Snick
rewatch as we break down all 13 of the
fox X-Men and Deadpool films ahead of
Wolverine's mutant homecoming and
Deadpool 3 in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in this terrifying election
year X2 reminds us how politically
charged Marvel mutant stories can get so
let's spend some time with pre Logan Bry
Brian Cox and break down all the new
Easter eggs things you never spotted and
which elements Kevin feige will bring
back in Deadpool 3 including the fact
that this film technically has the very
first Deadpool Cameo but if you want to
avoid any Deadpool 3 spoilers don't
worry I'm going to leave any kind of
spoiler conversation for the danger room
at the end of this video and to
celebrate this X-Men stick stick rewatch
we are doing a special X-Men themed
merch release which is really the best
way to support us at new rockstars grab
one of these designs by clicking in the
link in the description okay so during
the 20th Century Fox Fanfare and Logo
the X once again lingers like it did in
the first film this is the first X film
though in the series to use the Marvel
comic book book logo we would see this
in front of other Marvel films in the
ODS including the Sony Spider-Man films
Daredevil Punisher Ghost Rider fantastic
poor and the first few films produced by
Marvel Studios in partnership with other
Studios like Paramount Universal yep
when Kevin feige now says all Marvel
branded titles produced by other Studios
can come back via the Multiverse that
also includes Nick Cage Ghost Rider ping
fire and Ray Stevenson Punisher from
2008 Punisher war zone shotgunning a
guy's face off once again we open on
Patrick Stewart narrating as Charles X
Xavier um mutants the next Link in The
evolutionary chain or simply a new
species of Humanity on the words new
species a green star appears out of
nowhere within this red tinted nebula in
space forming into a humanoid figure
which must be the Phoenix Force the
deeper power within Gene gray who
emerges in this film a bald silhouette
in space though not unlike the imagery
Marvel Studios would borrow for The
Watcher in the wh if series Charles
wonders whether mutants are just what
humans evolve into or a fully different
species the answer to that question will
inform how well these tribes will share
the planet because as Charles says
sharing the world has never been
Humanity's defining attribute we push
into that green star in the Phoenix
Force's brain to enter the nerve
synapses under the opening titles in
last week's breakdown I described how
this was meant to show cbro what Charles
sees when he meditates behind that
locked door this time the brain tissue
is merged with techy plating and wiring
to reflect how cerebro's Machinery fuses
with Charles's mind a process that gets
hijacked in this movie remember these
early X-Men movies were coming out when
the predominant cultural force in
American sci-fi Cinema was The Matrix
films where Moody brain Meats machine
cyber Punk was really all the rage in
the previous movie the locked XTO of
cerebra opened to aitz this time it
opens to the emblem of the White House
as we find ourselves on a tour peering
over the shoulders of tourists looking
at this sign from The Gaze of this
mystery man in sunglasses we will soon
learn Allen coming as Kurt Vagner
Nightcrawler the tour guide quotes
Abraham Lincoln we are not enemies but
friends we must not not be enemies
though passion may have strained it must
not break the bonds of our affection
this is actually came by Jubilee voice
actor from X-Men evolution kiar aani hey
guys check this
out Allan cuming in 2003 was best known
as a stage actor much like Hugh Jackman
was before he was cast had won
awards for playing the MC in a Revival
of Cabaret and also small roles in
Golden Eye in Eyes Wide Shut the actor
speaks fluent German and he shares a
birthday with Mozart who's DS eray from
RE Willam and D minor plays during the
hallway fight with the Secret Service
agents now Beast Angel and Gambit were
all considered as new characters for
this film but they ultimately settled on
Nightcrawler instead since he felt like
the most Outsider option before we see
Nightcrawler teleporting we just hear
this great sound
effect so in the comics Wolverine's
claws go snicked and Nightcrawler goes
bam Technically when night carler
teleports though he transfers through
what's known as The Brimstone Dimension
which is why he comes out smelling like
sulfur and why in this movie he's
surrounded by smoke whenever this
happens he bamps to the portrait of JFK
this is while President McKenna is
addressing Jackie his secretary Jackie
who shares the first name with JFK's
first lady McKenna is played by actor
Cotter Smith and is original to X2 but
Smith had played Robert Kennedy in a
1983 TV movie and he's signing a
document that reads president's Eyes
Only In addition to JFK and Lincoln
there is also a portrait of William
mckenley so all three of these
presidents were assassinated in office
and were just reminded that no president
is safe Senator Kelly warned that this
would happen in the last film a girl in
Illinois who can walk through walls now
what's to stop her from walking into a
bank vault or into the White House super
attacks on the White House is a
nightmare scenario that we saw with
General Zod in Superman 2 and I am
terrified to see what the boys does with
this kind of thing this Oval Office set
is an exact Recreation but the hallways
were made wider to allow more room for
fighting this sequence smartly orients
us from the Vantage points of the
confused Secret Service agents with
frantic pans and cuts and rarely stays
too long with c hurt and I love this
shot that Dolly's right word through the
wall on Nightcrawler kicking the agent
through the glass it's an impossible
Glide but it matches the way Kurt is
kind of impossibly teleporting through
this Doorway to tackle the agent on the
other side he always needs to break a
threshold in order to go through it
first kind of like a vampire needing an
invitation to go through the other side
because he cannot teleport through a
wall that he can't see the other side of
now it all happens so fast the agents
can't even verify how many attackers
there are and adding to the confusion is
the fact that Nightcrawler can use his
tail as a fifth appendage to grab and
toss guns and fight two agents at once
his bamps leave these ribbon wisps of
smoke a trail of confusion as the Secret
Service doesn't know what is smoke and
what is flesh they lock down the oval
and the camera swoops through the
peephole a kind of David Venture type
shot here to the office outside and the
camera whip pans with increasing
disorientation but I love this peole
shot because it tells us how close
Nightcrawler is getting to them and as
he gets closer the edit shows more and
more of his acrobatics an overhead shot
showing his sweeping the leg of another
agent whipping another at the same time
and teleporting to to the side of
another agent to tackle him into that
doorway of that outer office that the
peole shot just established and this guy
says don't shoot and his eyes direct
them upward to the corner where Kurt has
suspended himself with his tail and
looks like he is floating a true horror
Freddy Krueger type jump scare for these
guys DS e Ray brings an extra level of
Terror because it is historically a
funeral composition originally a
Gregorian chant dated back to the 13th
century and it's part of a poem
describing the last judgment of souls in
front of God which is a hint of
Nightcrawler's religious Affinity his
belief that he is a creature of EV who
needs to be judged by God but the music
cuts out right as the guards start
firing at the spot Nightcrawler was
seconds before just in time for us to
experience the terrifying muffled sounds
that the president hears outside of its
door at one point they hear sounds above
them kind of like in a horror
movie and then the door opens and then
one agent gets snatched into the abyss
and it's like we're in the middle of a
storm or a smoke bomb has been exploded
the music returns and now finally do we
see each of nightcrawlers beautiful
moves in slow motion as president
McKenna is being held down by his agents
because he is able to see it all go down
kind of like feeling like his life is
slowing down at the moment of his death
Kurt pins the president and we focus on
his sharp teeth his eyes he lifts the
dagger but one agent fires and clips his
arm and Kurt lets out an animal likee
Yelp it's a good thing the agent waited
to shoot until after the dagger moved
from one side of his body to the other
because Kurt drops it the moment he
teleports directly beneath him and this
time it's inches to the side of
McKenna's belly now this ribbon reads
mutant Freedom now now if we were
thinking about this which we shouldn't
be thinking about this moment happened
so fast if a mutant were powerful enough
to kill the president why would they
take credit for it this way who would
this message even be for the vice
president who would have a tougher time
passing any Mutant rights legislation
after this as a result clearly this is a
false flag orchestrated by someone who
wants to use it as a predicate to move
against mutants as we'll learn later
it's William Striker but this movie
begins in such a state of excitement and
fear that it doesn't give us time to
think we begin this movie as disoriented
as any Mutant fearing human would be
okay onto the snowy Canadian mountains
Wolverine gets a wide view of the
hydroelectric Dam foreshadowing the
uneven water levels that will later lead
to Jean's drowning he follows this wolf
to the alkal lake industrial complex but
gets no answers as we cross dissolve to
a stuffed wolf as storm gives a lecture
to her students neanderthals we once
believed that they were wiped out by
years of conflict with the much more
more advanced branch of humanity called
crom magnum man so storm goes on to say
that recent research suggested that the
two species may have entered bread
evolving into modern humans so remember
that deleted scene from the first film
showed storm lecturing about Roman
Emperor Constantine's conversion to
Christianity now she lectures about how
two stages of evolution of a single
species can still coexist Hal Berry
dropped the Kenyan accent for the sequel
and her role was beefed up after winning
the Oscar for Monsters ball according to
Alan he joined Hal Barry Hugh
Jackman Patrick Stewart James Marsen and
F Jansen in full costume confronting
director Brian Singer in his trailer
over his reported abuse of painkillers
temper tantrums on set his propensity to
just disappear from set for long periods
singer reportedly responded by saying
you people are full of and hi Barry
reportedly said I've heard enough you
can kiss my black ass so yes this is a
great movie it just probably wasn't a
very fun one for them to make the young
mutant Arty sticks out his Fork tongue
to this human girl he will call this
back in the final scene was Striker
among the mutant students is a girl with
a French jacket this was supposed to be
Danielle Moonstar AKA Mirage there was
an extended version of this Museum scene
in which we would have seen Kia Wong
lighting up her fingers with electricity
as this movie's Jubilee she actually
shows up in the final scene in Charles
Xavier's office one student checks out
the skeleton of a saber-tooth a nod to
the character saber-tooth Tyler M and
Ray Park were supposed to return for X2
as saber Toth and Toad but apparently
there were some scheduling conflicts and
the script is already pretty packed with
mutants as it was but now ever since
Liberty Island Jean Gray's telepathy has
been far more powerful and she hears all
the voices around her Mak me insane when
she
does to the
shelter I love the sound mix here
because three of those voices were audio
clips from different parts of the movie
to the shelter was the secret service
agent to the shelter to the shelter no
was Logan's voice later on no and
they're going to kill him was Rogue
later on they're going to kill him
they're going to kill him so the Phoenix
force is allowing Jean to hear voices
from the future she is detached from
time I theorized last week that Phoenix
is not bound by time and she was able to
connect with Logan presently for him in
the weapon x lab in the 1980s again we
will see in Xmen Days of Future Past
Consciousness based time travel is
possible in this universe Rogue Bobby
Drake Iceman and Pyro who's now been
recasting this movie as Aaron Stanford
tangle with some teens in the food court
pyro holds a personalized lighter and
blazing with a shark design which
apparently is an homage to Jaws which
Ryan Singer was his favorite movie
Charles freezes everyone before the
situation gets out of hand but leaves
the mutants able to move this just shows
how Charles can in an instant with J's
mind separate all mutants and humans
with just his mental Powers many of the
extras in the scene were actually played
by mimes because they were just so good
at holding still I want to imagine that
one guy in the Oval Office later who
just freezes with a pin in his mouth
that guy's got to be a mime right okay a
newscast details Nightcrawler's attack
at the White House and right under the
TV it's a sign that says smoking is not
permitted in the museum which makes
those guys asking for life from pyro
extra so back at the Academy
they discuss the White House attack Jean
sits across from the chessboard from
Charles and she toys with the Rook with
her heightened Phoenix powers in this
movie she is arguably on par with
Charles in the next film will be a
conflict between the X-Men and Phoenix
we are introduced to Colonel Striker
played by Brian Cox of succession Fame
in a number of other roles so Striker is
adapted from Reverend striker in the
comics who is a religious fanatic and
tell of angelist that writer Chris
Claremont based on Jerry fwell striker
in this movies accompanied by eureko
oyama Lady Death Strike played by Kelly
who who has exactly one line of dialogue
in this entire film she cracks her
knuckles with these unsettling loud
almost mechanical cracking noises a hint
at her adamantium skeleton I find it
interesting though that Striker refuses
the drink from the president maybe from
that dark past with his son Jason caus
his wife to take a drill to her head the
guy just doesn't want to be inebriated
in any state because you know he's
inebriating every mutant he can get his
hands on President McKenna brings in
Senator Kelly who's actually mystique
and disguise as we learned from the end
of the first film and while this movie
doesn't address it has Mystique been
going around as Senator Kelly fulltime
is she making all of his appointments
votes hearings fundraisers campaign
events how does she have all this time
Striker dropped some satellite photos of
the jet at Xavier's School this facility
is a school sure it is ah this movie
came out in 2003 after Secretary State
colen Powell went before the UN with
satellite imagery of the facilities he
claimed were building wmds in Iraq which
the Bush Administration of course used
as justification to invade the country
if you're old enough you remember
watching the news where it was often
debated whether an aerial shot of
something was a school or a combatant
training camp Striker says I was pil in
Black Ops missions in the jungles of
North Vietnam where you were sucking on
your mama's Ted Woodstock Kelly but
actually in Xmen Days of Future Past
alternate timeline versions of Mystique
and Striker do run into each other and
fight in Vietnam so Bobby tries to kiss
Rogue and Peter respu and Colossus draws
a doodle making fun of them we saw Peter
sketching by the pond in the first film
Logan returns and he gets Frosty
greetings from both Bobby and Scott it's
this classic Dynamic when the Bad Boy
comes back to visit all the nice guys
just start growling in his plastic
prison Eric lyer listens to Mozart's
Serenade Number 13 and G major as he
reads th Whit's The Once and Future King
this is about the legend of King Arthur
as a figure who will one day return to
continue ruling as king of Britain this
is called back at the end of the film
have any of you read a book by an
English novelist named th white called
The Once in future ging Eric's book is a
wornout first edition copy of the
collection which was published in 1958
but remember in the years since X-Men 2
Ian McKellen had appeared as Gandalf in
fellowship and in two towers and would
later this year in 2003 appear in Return
of the King so seeing him reading The
Once and Future King just carried a
deeper lay of meaning for all the nerds
highing in the theater of which I was
one of them in addition to the metal
free chess set from the first film's
final scene we see that Charles sleeps
on a mattress is essentially an
inflatable pool raft his jumpsuit though
is numbered 00001 as Eric is the first
and likely only mutant in this facility
and Eric as someone particularly
triggered by humans being tagged with
numbers he must feel especially stung to
be the first number in whatever this new
wave of genocide is going to be Charles
shows Wolverine cerebro with non-mutated
humans represented in white and mutants
represented in red like a chess board
there are two sides two colors on this
world map there's a particularly bright
spot in the Washington DC area that
would be around where Magneto is being
kept Mystique transforms from Kelly to
eure back into herself to access
Striker's computer in the most Easter
egg pack scene of the movie there are
tons of important names on this thing a
few being characters that we will see
later in this franchise or later in the
MCU on the drop down menu we see John
allise that's pyro Amara Akila that's
magma Allison Blair that's dazzler Sally
Bevin skids Elizabeth brck psylock Maria
Castellanos that's Ferell Cassidy 2
revers Sean Cassidy Banshee and Teresa
siren Lyla Cheney associate of the X-Men
in the New Mutants Victor Creed
saber-tooth Roberto a Casta that's
Sunspot Lura danne that's Polaris Bobby
Drake Iceman Fred Dukes blob we'll meet
him in Xmen Origins Angelo Espinosa skin
Kyle Gibney Wild Child Guthrie 2 refers
to Paige Guthrie husk and Sam Guthrie
Cannonball kucho harata that Silver
Samurai we'll see them in the Wolverine
Garris and Kane that's Weapon X from
xforce a version of them was going to be
in the original draft of Deadpool Remy
leau Gambit Eric lyncher Magneto Arty
Maddox is at Fork tongue kid from the
museum earlier Jamie Madrox is Multiple
Man Gian Koy man is karma Max off to
reverse to of course the mutants W to
Maxim off Scarlet Witch and Petro Maxim
off Quicksilver and we had two different
versions of quicksilver the Evan Peters
one in the X-Men films and then the
Aaron Taylor Johnson version in the MCU
Kevin mctaggert likely refers to Proteus
son of Moira mctaggert and Daniel
Moonstar Mirage who shows up a New
Mutants in Aurora Monro storm and then a
few seconds later on the other screen
many of these names reappear along with
new folders with new names including
root batf that's Sabra Cecilia Reyes the
mutant doctor in the New Mutants Everett
Thomas sink Nicole and claudet Croy
those are the psychic twins Kurt Vagner
Nightcrawler Raven darkh Mystique
Vanessa Carlow copycat Wade Wilson
Deadpool his first Marvel movie Cameo
Scott summer Cyclops Doug Ramsey Cipher
Andrea Andreas Von strucker those are
the twins who become Fenris eure oyama
so I guess Striker got a file for her
too Tom Cassidy AKA black Tom Cassidy we
see a version of him and Deadpool 2
David North AKA Maverick and agent Smith
ttha Smith boom boom Calvin Ranken mimik
Dr Nathaniel Essex Mr Sinister who was
set up in the post credit scene of X-Men
apocalypse and rumor has it might be a
major villain when the X-Men come into
the MCU Mortimer 20 be toad Iana
Rasputin magic who's played by Anya
Taylor joy and New Mutants Teresa RoR
again is Teresa R Cassidy siren shirro
Yoshida Sunfire weido caracella strong
guy Katherine Kitty Pride Shadow Cat and
Dr Carl Leos Sauron now other folders
are labeled Omega Red that refers to an
X-Men villain Xavier school you know
what that is Blackbird you know what
that is Massachusetts Academy refers to
the new site of Xavier School in the
comics tras that's bolevard tras creator
of the Sentinels we see him played by
Peter Dinklage in Days of Future Past
gra Malin refers to Jonas gyin a mutant
whose strength depends on light exposure
Zero Tolerance refers to an X-Men comic
storyline project Wide Awake is part of
the Sentinel creation operation so we
see Alpha flight beta flight and Gamma
flight in different spots those refer to
Canadian mutant teams Department H is
what oversees those teams Jamie bradic
is psylock older brother who can
manipulate reality danger room we know
what that is that's the training room of
the X-Men and where we talk about
spoilers Forge is a techsavvy weapons
expert Brotherhood that's the name of
Magneto's crew Weapon X obviously
Striker's operation rain St Clair is
Wolf Spain that's one of the New Mutants
who's played by Maisy Williams in the
New Mutants film cerebro know what that
is legacy is a virus that was released
by Strife against the mutants Salem
Center is also another name for Xavier's
Academy Franklin Richards this is the
son of Reed Richards ansu storm who is
defined as an Omega Level mutant and
when John krinski Reed Richards referred
to the fact that he had kids technically
Franklin Richards exists in MCU
continuity somewhere Island refers to
the research center created by Moira MCT
tager Rose Burn plays her in first class
and that's supposed to be Moira in the
post-edit scene of The Last Stand
morlocks is the underground mutant group
Kevin mctaggert is Moos Sonic a protus
thank you to better help for sponsoring
this video A new year is a great excuse
for finally tackling the stuff that you
put off last year and if one of the
things you've been putting off until
2024 is taking proper care of your
mental health better help can help you
get started and hey no judgment for
waiting starting therapy can be hard and
the right therapist for you might not be
in your area and some people struggle
with the face to face in interaction of
therapy with better help you can have
your therapy sessions as a phone call as
a video chat or even via messaging if
you prefer that whatever is the most
comfortable version of therapy for you
just click the link in the description
and answer a few questions about what
you're looking for from therapy and what
your preferences are better help will
then match you with the therapist from
their Network that's right for you if
you don't really fit with that therapist
which is a common thing with therapy you
can easily switch to a therapist for no
additional cost without stressing about
insurance who is in your network or
anything like that if you think you
might benefit from therapy consider
betterhelp click the link in the
description or visit betterhelp.com
rockstars clicking that link helps
support this Channel and also gets you
10% off your first month of better help
so you can connect with a therapist to
see if it helps you they also snuck in
some crew names on the guard IDs we see
Tom Danto the executive producer who
helped write the first film script as
well as Michael dowty and Dan Harris
they are co-writers one of the names is
El Donner referring to Lauren Schuler
Doner the executive producer there's
also a photo director Brian Singer who
also shows up Wheeling Charles in to
visit Eric now outside the church where
Nightcrawler is hiding graffiti reads
nature laughs last which is a alteration
on the comment saying nature always has
a last laugh detailing the law of
entropy which states that everything in
nature every system will increase in
disorder in chaos basically man plans
God laughs or a reflection of how
despite human's efforts to Stamp Out
mutants natural selection will find a
way when Gene and storm enter this
church Kurt yells at them in
German you bored yet which translated
means get out I am a minion of the devil
I am a spawn of evil in the comics Kurt
is deeply religious and even study to be
a priest at one point while he was still
in the X-Men as Jee tends to his wounds
Nightcrawler gestures to Jesus Christ
perhaps he is testing me in 2022 is
Immortal X-Men number one the character
Exodus actually implies that Jesus was a
mutant Wolverine dreams of alkali Lake
and the champagne glasses returned but
now they add more images Striker
snapping his dog tag in half which is
what they do to a soldier who's Kia but
notice at the end of this movie Logan
will leave Striker with the second half
of that dog tag Wolverine meets this
mutant kid Jones who's blinking to
change channels most of the channels
reporting on the White House attack but
there is this one science museum are
claiming to have exper yeah this is a
report of Charles freezing everyone at
the science museum the day before
because yeah everyone at that museum
would be pretty freaked out Charles and
Eric recall Colonel Striker's son Jason
fortunately I wasn't able to help him at
least not in the way that his father
wanted as all of these movies depict
mutation as a metaphor for the gay
rights movement this suggests that
Striker hoped that Charles Xavier's
facility would be a form of conversion
therapy and we see this mutant LGBT
parallel mostly with the character of
Bobby Drake in this film who tells Logan
that his parents think that this is a
prep school Bobby dates Rogue in these
films but in the comics Bobby Drake was
famously confirmed to be gay in 2015 the
nature documentary that Jones Is
Watching actually mimics exactly what
happens in this movie sensing danger the
mother rat races home the babies can't
even see the Killer and someone
Uninvited is coming to
dinner she arrives too late for one baby
now Jones gets hit with some darts but
don't worry he reappears and X in The
Last Stand but this attack on the school
is an A+ sequence that emphasizes this
movie's themes of fear of the other
because after empathetically relating to
the fear of the humans in the opening
now we're afraid of how fear would turn
government forces into people who raid a
school of children Wolverine is the best
babysitter it's so satisfying to see him
go full Berserker you picked the wrong
house
B you want to shoot me shoot me but they
actually removed a few extra seconds of
footage from after Wolverine stabs a
soldier in the kitchen for NPA ratings a
longer more violent version of this is
in the special edition now Jackman was
obviously great in the first X-Men movie
but in next two is when he starts going
full rage mode for any of these action
sequences screaming himself horse and
taking us to the gun show the series
takes really a turn here transforming
Wolverine into a parental figure setting
him up for the Lone Wolf and Cub
relationship that he'll have with x23
and Logan Kitty Pride played by Katie
Stewart before the character was recast
as Elliot page in the Last Stand phases
through the bed and the walls siren
played by Shauna Kane wakes up and
sounds the alarm across the school
Colossus who appear earlier in the movie
played by Daniel Cudmore medals up
Striker hints at his and Wolverine's
shared past but Bobby forms an ice wall
between Logan and Striker like the
opening sequence Logan is being iced out
of his past this ice ball is actually a
practical effect and weighed 3,500 lb
when Wolverine and the kids used Cyclops
car they get into a Mazda RX8 concept
that was made just for the movie kind of
like the Dr Pepper product placement
earlier Mazda was another tie-in sponsor
for the film the blue paint is a special
tint that Mazda called mutant blue and
the X in the RX8 the back was also
enlarged to emphasize the movie's
branding but in the scar pyro tries to
break the Silence with music and
accidentally plays ins syncs bye bye bye
on full blast Brian Singer was
apparently friends with Instinct member
JC Shaz even as late as X-Men apocalypse
in 2016 come on Shaz everyone knew who
Brian was at that point as Wolverine
speeds down the road notice there are no
headlights now I get it it's to avoid
detection but you know this is not safe
Logan you're more likely to get pulled
over by a patrol car in the bar on the
TV is Dr Hank McCoy AKA Beast played by
actor Steve B before Kelsey gramar
played him in the Last Stand also on the
show is the mention of a Mr Shaw which
is an OD to Sebastian Shaw the leader of
the hellfire club who Kevin Bacon plays
in X-Men first Class the newscaster
hosting the debate is actually a cameo
by David K voice of Professor X in X-Men
evolution now let's see if I can get
apocalypse's attention but this Bar B
set where Mystique hooks up with the
guard was actually built for the first
movie for a flashback to the onset of
Scott's powers and his accidental
destroying of his high school bathroom
that scene was recreated in X-Men
apocalypse with Ty Sheridan Rebecca rain
gets to play without makeup for this
scene but she does wear this tight blue
dress to hint at Raven's natural skin
Striker confronts Charles over the
tragedy of his son Jason who he
introduces in this movie as mutant 143
this version of Jason Striker is based
on Jason windguard aka the mutant
Mastermind and starting in 2013 the
character was reintroduced in allnew
X-Men number 19 as Jason Striker William
Striker's son at Bobby's house we see
several snow themed posters on the wall
of his bedroom snowboarding ski as this
kid probably would have enjoyed snow
Sports where he could have tested out
his powers without people noticing as
much Wolverine draws his claws on the
cat who purs and licks claws but listen
closely yeah did Wolverine hurt that cat
when he retracted his claw I hope he
just scared it cuz we do see the cat get
picked up later I think the cat's okay I
think the mark of a great action movie
is if it has had at least three great
sequences and Magneto's prism break is
one of them in this one Eric listens to
Mozart and notices something different
about loreo
no it's not that from the closeup of
Eric's smile to his slow rise with the
Shadows under his eyes this time hiding
his bruises it's all storyboarded like a
great comic page Charles lifts loreo too
much iron in your blood and he sucks the
molten metal that Mystique injected into
his blood it's so sick this power status
shift it's totally unage to Hannibal
lecter's Escape in the Silence of the
Lambs where the white dressed elderly
super villain overpowers the guards in a
bloody display for what it's worth Brian
Cox actually played Hannibal before
Anthony Hopkins in the very first
Hannibal movie Manhunter we're reminded
of Eric's single fired bullet in the
first film and with just a few ounces of
metal he now obliterates the glass cell
and flat one into a disc to fly upon I'm
pretty sure it's still stained with
traces of blood of loreo when he steps
on it one detail I always love is the
look of Glee on Ian McKellen's face as
he floats toward the guard booth and
unleashes those metal orbs on them so in
the scene Bobby comes out to his family
Ian McKellen who is gay reportedly
worked with the writers to help make the
scene feel authentic Bobby's mother says
this is her fault but John says that
males carry the mutant Gene which is
interesting biologically as a y
chromosome is far smaller than the X
chromosome and typically doesn't carry
many genetic traits of any but in a way
this shifts a responsibility so to speak
on William Striker for his son Jason and
to underline this coming out parallel
Bobby's mom later asks him have you
tried not being a mutant but Bobby's
shitty brother calls the Boston PD I
love how all these cops make sure to
have their Boston accents and JN sprays
him with fire Rogue absorbs his power to
reduce the Flames Jason Striker
meanwhile projects an illusion in
Charles's Mind of a time when they were
at the expansion together at first
Charles is shown standing like how he
stood when he projected himself Senator
Kelly's memory in the first film and
when he walks around in Wanda maximoff's
mind in multiv vers vanis just a simple
way to show the audience when we are
inside of a mind versus reality but
notice how Jason cleverly keeps Charles
in the wheelchair for the second time he
goes into his mind which makes it hard
for Charles to know what's reality and
what's illusion the Blackbird is
approached by Two fighter jets and the
one who signals them is Captain rayun
lie a reference to Ray rayun Li a comic
artist and concept artist credited
graphic designer for this X2 film Ray
was also a concept artist for the 2003
Battle Star Galactica miniseries and in
the 20 Battle Star Galactica there is a
similar Easter egg on a jet storm tries
to fend off the pilots with tornadoes
but fails to saave off the last two
missiles Gene awakens her Phoenix Force
Powers destroying one of the missiles
but fails to stop the second Rogue gets
sucked out of the jet but Nightcrawler
teleports to catch her without waiting
for anyone to direct him I love
Nightcrawler in this movie Magneto
catches the whole jet though when will
these people learn how to fly which is a
meta joke referring to the fact that in
the X-Men comics and TV shows some of
these X-Men just use their powers to fly
like everyone can fly technically
Magneto though does not fly in these
movies he just lifts his body with
Magnetic forces but they really go to
efforts in this movie to make sure that
storm does not fly she just kind of like
levitates by wind Magneto tells
Wolverine that Striker was the source of
his itam manam on his bones and Logan
says that they already searched the
alkal Lake Compound but Magneto responds
once again you think it's all about you
calling back Eric's cadd line to Logan
on the train but really all these X-Men
movies are like about Wolverine they
should just call the Wolverine franchise
Wolverine and Jean share a kiss since
Scott is out of the picture now Cyclops
is the leader of the X-Men in the
animated series and in most of the
comics but he unfortunately gets
sideline for most of these movies
presumably because his optic blast was a
costly visual effect in the early ODS
nowadays notice how glowing energy
blasts are like the cheapest visual
effect 80% of MCU character's powers are
just like blasting light from different
parts of their bodies Mystique enters
Wolverine's tent as Gene but Logan finds
a scars he left on her stomach in
Liberty Island making us wonder if
Mystique isn't able to shape shift over
certain scar tissue or maybe if she just
wanted Wolverine to find these marks to
mess with them no one's ever left a scar
quite like you in another subtle nod to
Hannibal Lector Magneto cat calls Rogue
we love what you're done with your hair
it's similar to one of my favorite
moments in the Silence of the Lambs oh
and Senator just one more thing love
your suit magnito meets pyro what's your
real name John I appreciate the cult
Orthodoxy of Magneto he understands that
the real battle is recruiting from the
younger generation this gives a dual
purpose to the superhero monikers of
these films it's really a way for these
mutants to reclaim their identities pyro
says I can only manipulate the fire I
can't create it you are a God among
insects yeah there's definitely a
parallel to Prometheus here from Greek
mythology the Titan who stole fire from
the gods now they send in Wolverine
actually Mystique posing as him but
Striker is not fooled the one thing I
know better than anyone is my own work
seal the room shoot it how does Striker
see through this impersonation from
across the room it's not the appearance
it's the emotion because Striker knows
that Wolverine would look at him and at
all this facility with rage in his eyes
because remember earlier you want to
shoot me shoot me that is the true
Wolverine a wolverine this calm would
totally be a red flag to Striker and
remember Striker's computer had a file
on Raven Mystique so he's completely
prepared for a metamor of trying to
infiltrate anything he has I just love
it when villains are smart we also got
to get props to Striker for his plan
here tricking Charles into thinking he's
in his home cerebra when he's really in
a false duplicate that Striker had
constructed it's like the con used by
the crew in Oceans 11 when he can't
break into a vault build your own
replica Vault and lure in the mark to
help you break into his own Vault
Mystique flips him off with a backward
slide a move that she learned from Logan
in the first film and she morphs into a
striker immediately it happens so fast
and props to Brian Cox for doing his own
little moves here we have a metor
could be anybody
what I love it when other actors
impersonate what Mystique would do as
them in these movies so the X-Men
rejoined mystique and Magneto a large
portion of energy from the dam has been
diverted to this chamber cerebro there
it is yeah you can hear the call to
opportunity in Eric's voice because his
plan is to take control of cerebro and
twist it for his own agenda and again we
are just seeing smart villains making
smart choices yet Jean is on to them she
doesn't want to leave them alone Striker
Whispers in Jason's ear to make Charles
link with all the mutants to kill them
Charles earlier warning to Logan to make
him think he was a little girl now seems
ironic it's the illusion of a little
girl that fools Charles yet we should
note that Jason Striker projects himself
as a different gender which adds a
deeper layer of tragedy for the
character as they were misunderstood by
their father Nightcrawler and Storm find
the detain mutant kids and seconds
before Kurt teleports into the chamber
if you brighten the shot of the kids
looking up at him you can see Allen
coming in the background they used a
shot of the actor before he stepped
forward out of the shadows and you can
really only see this if you have like an
OLED screen at home with the brightness
settings way uped Wolverine finds the
weapon xlb with with x-ray scans that we
saw flashes of earlier but now we see
them more closely including ones of him
as well as death strike's hand but there
are a few other possible test subjects
from over the years the skull with
spikes that could belong to quill and
then the shoulder Wing that could belong
to Angel both of these characters we
meet in the Last Stand Wolverine finds
the molten Adam mantium and the hoses
using his surgery and he flashes back
again to one of his Memories One of the
Military Officers has this patch of a
black horse on a red and white field
this is for the US Army's 11th armored
Cavalry Regiment worth noting that
canonically to the Marvel Comics
Wolverines pass with Weapon X was the US
government's attempt to recreate the
super soldier success that they had with
Steve Rogers during World War II with
adamantium being a synthetic alloy of
vibranium Striker says that the reason
this lab is still set up this way is
that they cannot ever let adamantium
cool making it in a way a kind of
Eternal Flame or an evil Fountain of
Youth forever bubbling for certain rapid
healing victims of the
military-industrial complex Death Strike
was yet another of these test subjects
but as Striker leaves he passes morg
corpse drawers suggesting dozens of
others might have died when death strike
extend her claw we can see that they are
segmented as if each segment was stacked
inside of the other you know like a
lightsaber toys that would really be the
only way these claws could fit into her
flanges actress Kelly who had real prop
adamantium Nails which were glued to the
bottom of her fingernails this fight is
brutal and Wolverine ends it by plugging
her with more adamantium this movie
plugging people with molten metal two
crazy gnarly deaths using the same kind
of closeup in the last second you can
actually see Striker's brainwash serum
fading from her eyes as she looks with
Lucid awareness at Logan and the
adamantium leaks from her eyes like
tears it's just a striking reminder to
Logan that these mutants are not each
other's enemies it's the government
forces that did this to them Jason and
Charles link with all the mutants
deleted scenes would have shown other
mutants including the Hank McCoy we saw
earlier transforming into his Beast form
Gambit Remy labau playing cards and his
energy flaring up actually this kind of
psionic seizure from Charles Xavier is
the dark fate that awaits most of the
X-Men in the Years leading up to the
events of Logan Magneto pulls the pin
out of all the soldiers grenades whoa
boom and he opens a cerebro chamber
since Eric helped Charles build cerebro
he knows what tiles to rec figure and
Mystique impersonates Striker to flip
cerebro to Target humans instead
throughout this film Nightcrawler has
needed to see his destination before he
bamps into it that's why actually there
was that creepy shot of him peeking
through the doorway in the white house
earlier and he needed all the doors to
be open before he entered them but storm
uses their exchange about Blind Faith to
get him to teleport into the cerebro
chamber the bamp occurs precisely on the
part of the Lord's Prayer as it is in
heaven as it is in heaven as far as Kurt
knew this moment of transfer could have
taken him directly to his death and
anytime he transfers he is going through
the brimstone Dimension to get there so
he's kind of praying In This Moment take
me through hell but take me to heaven on
the other side of it please and there
storm lowers the temperature to get
Jason drop his projection and they leave
poor Jason Striker there to die even
though he was being chemically
brainwashed by his father to do what he
did sacrifices on both sides the Dam
breaks and Jean Gray exits the black
bird to stop the flood water a little
detail I just noticed behind Scott and
Logan you can see Kurt shifting around
and then some pre- Brimstone Dimension
smoke forming as he is trying to
teleport to save Jean but she is
stopping him the Phoenix Force Rises out
of Jee and again it's just a bit of a
bummer that Cyclops James Marsden is
sidelined in this film other than to
Moren and Jee In This Moment something
the actor has to do from behind this
bulky eyepiece but I love that Logan is
the one to hug Scott afterwards because
this battle began with Mankind's fear of
mutants to extinguish it they returned
to Where it All Began inside of The
White House Oval Office as Charles
interrupts President McKenna's address
the mutants appear suddenly among
McKenna's advisers faster even the
Nightcrawler could teleport making me
think that Charles even made the
president blackout for an additional
second they present some paperwork from
Striker's office to prove his wrongdoing
and Charles says that he knows a girl
who can walk through walls of course
referencing Kitty Pride but this is also
a Veiled Threat to the president that
that mystery mutant from Illinois that
Senator Kelly ranted about is yet
another mutant beside Nightcrawler who
can get to him but the symbolism is
important here Charles positions all
these mutants so that they are standing
among the humans in the room he wants to
posee a united front to the president to
give him a glimpse at a possible future
where president's inter advisers can
include both humans and mutants and both
sides can be at the levers of power
because mutants and humans are not on
opposite sides of the chess board they
are really in This Together the previous
film ended with a chess match and
Charles alludes to another match here
the next move is yours back at the
school Charles senses Jean's presence
outside the window looks directly into
the camera because Jean is still alive
in the form of the Phoenix Force he
begins his lecture involving th whites
The Once and Future King showing that he
and Eric are still part of that book
club whereas Charles normally takes us
in and out of these movies now Jean's
voice takes over quoting Charles opening
words from the first movie as a
silhouette of a phoenix appears beneath
the water but every few 100
Millennia Evolution leaps forward and we
will pick up with Phoenix's future and
next week's breakdown to The Last Stand
but quickly some Deadpool 3 spoilers in
the danger room if you're curious
succession actor Brian Cox Bean in this
film reminds us that the Tom WS Gans to
his Logan Roy Matthew mcfan is playing
some role in Deadpool 3 online rumors
claimed a TVA agent named Paradox but
apparently that claim it said that they
made that up to full other scoopers so
who knows okay the best way to sport any
rockstars is to grab some X-Men inspired
merch at nerd riot. shop follow me on
all social platforms at e AOS And
subscribe to all three channels in the
newars network thanks for watching and
I'll see you next week 60
[Music]
by